[音楽]
俺を呼んだのは
君かい僕ですこんにちははじめしゃちょー
ですおい
夏が来たな皆の衆見てください今日の天気
超
晴天の
熱々そらすごいよちょっと見て
気持ち悪い気持ちいいでしょ逆にこんだけ
広いとねちょっとこうお家にこもりっぱ
なしのインドアYouTuberはじめ
しゃちょーからするとちょっと苦しいん
ですけれどもせっかく夏だし天気もいい
そしてご覧ください最近作りました屋上
テラスこれ見てもらったら分かると思うん
ですけども結構ね縦に広いんですよという
わけで今日はですねボウリングしていき
たいと思います
というわけで今日はですねせっかくご覧
くださいこの
縦長のテラスがあるということで
[音楽]
先生俺は
家で居酒屋がして屋上にテラスがあるん
だったら俺ここを今日居酒屋にしたいビア
ガーデインにしたいんですけどここ最高
じゃないですか
居酒屋といえば冷奴
焼き鳥だろ焼き鳥焼き鳥ですね
居酒屋で言えばお酒の焼き鳥でこう食べ
ながらつまむあの酒がうまい
じゃん
なあ分かってるようなというわけで今日は
この縦に長い屋上テラスに
バカ長い焼き鳥作りたいと思いましたこう
いうこういう
イメージ
こうやって
[音楽]
投げないですけどせっかくだったら面白い
作りたいのでこの長さを生かした超ロング
焼き鳥作ってみたいと思いますお酒を添え
てねでは作っていきましょう
はいというわけでご覧ください
鉄板の数これでねやりすぎだねそこら辺の
バーベキューよりはたくさんありますけど
もこれをまず1回縦に置いていきたいと
思います
一番持っちゃいけない人が持ってる
準備できたこれが今日の
焼き鳥の串です
この屋上テラスだからこそこうやって
焼き鳥焼きたいですよこうやってただし
何かやばいけどね
早速
焼き鳥を作る準備していきたいと思います
まずは長い机置きます
いいね
はいというわけでプレート完成しました
ご覧ください
これ
停電しないよねうちいやー
わかんねーどうなんだろうちゃんと全部
温まればいいですけどもだけど準備ができ
ました
ちょっと暑いですね
暑いですねお疲れ様でした待って待って
待って待って待って待って待ってもう飲み
たいもう飲みたい飲みたい飲みたい飲み
たい飲みたい飲みたい
これマジでうまそうじゃないやばいんだ
けど水滴で何も見えんキンキに成績でマジ
でやばいんだよこれうわ手が冷たいもう
これねちょっと新しくなったみたいなので
よりちょっとおいしくなったみたいで今
すぐ飲みたいところなんですけどもう
居酒屋メニューと合うらしくても焼き鳥と
かベストナッツなのよきっと今ちょっと
ここグッとこらえて他のメンバーとも下に
いるのでちょっとでっかい焼き鳥作って
みんなで焼き鳥食べながら
美味しくお酒を飲みましょう
焼き鳥できてくるのが絶対おいしいから俺
は待つよ
頑張って作っていきます絶対飲みません
はいというわけで食材届きました
鶏肉とネギですね焼き鳥いればネギなので
これをちょっと頑張って串にさせていき
たいと思いますと悪くなる前にどんどん
やっていくよさせていきます1号機行き
ます
ほら
来た来た入りましたこれをどこまで行けば
いいんだ
これどこまで行くの
はい
急げ押し込み作戦で
4階に1回ネギが来ますなるほど
計算されてるとちゃんとね
居酒屋なのでいらっしゃいません来た来た
来た
破壊しちゃったちょっと
太すぎて入んないぞ
焼き鳥なんでネギは入れないです
肉の日だけはちょっとタイヤが落ちてきて
ちょっと作業しやすい今この曇りのうちに
俺は完成させるぞ待ってろ先さっきこれ
ちょっとずつ
詰まってくるような肉がこれもう一人
欲しい人そうですね
刺す人と動かす人が欲しいなというわけで
チケット読みました第3助けて
[音楽]
ちょっと
焼き鳥作ってるんで焼き鳥手伝ってもらっ
ていいですか今日は1日限定の4億円
ハウス居酒屋です
居酒屋ビアガーデン
バーカウンターバーカウンター
こんなね
素敵なね
[音楽]
飲んでた気づいたら気づいたらごめん
ごめんごめん
新しくなったみたいです飲んでみたんです
けど
美味しくなってますねこれ
炭酸が強くなってる感じがしたし
ゆずの香りもアップしてますもうこのね夏
にめっちゃぴったりですこれ
最高だ
いや本当においしい
ですお疲れ様でした本当に水神相談ね
焼き鳥とかと食べると絶対もっと美味しい
のでまだね俺はね本領発揮してないと思う
んですよできるまで飲みながら待ちたいと
思います
[音楽]
すいません先に飲んでしまいました19
強くなってきたので取りに行くが悪くなる
前に先にさしてやるところだけもう
プレートで焼いちゃいます
火を通しましょう
[音楽]
完成しました
全長4mの焼き鳥です
すいませんネギは無理でしたネギ入れよう
としたんですけども
串が太すぎてちょっとネギばれちゃって
ちょっと入らなかったので無事に肉だけの
焼き鳥になりましたこれ通常サイズです
通常サイズと比べるとこんな感じですね
若干大きいです
はいというわけで
完成しましたもうこのテラスにふさわしい
サイズだよね横長だからこそ準備できた
焼き鳥ではないでしょうが4mってこれ
すごいよねすごいじゃあちょっと早速
健介の僕で食べたいと思いますその前に
写真だけ撮っとこうかなせっかくだしね
かっこいい
ロック画面にしようじゃあちょっと
持ち上げてみますいきますよ321
重った絶対モテないのとあと結構すいませ
ん
肉が焼くと縮まっちゃってどんどん
ちょっとポロポロってなっちゃったりした
のですいませんあの動かせませんただ一応
結構ひっついてるよね串にはお肉取ってる
のでちゃんと焼き鳥だと思います早速食べ
てみましょうではいただきます
どっちから先行こうかなまあ飲み物準備し
といた方がいいじゃないですか
このキンキンのグラスになぁ入れますね
[音楽]
音を聞けみんな
入れます
この時のために頑張ったまである本当に
来た来た来た来た
[音楽]
はい入りましたいや
グラスの色めっちゃ綺麗おしゃれどっち
から行くこれどっちから行きたいまずは
ちょっと暑いので
飲んじゃっていいですかまずは
いただきます
[音楽]
やばいやばいここからさらに焼き鳥食べ
たらもっと美味しいんだよねじゃあ焼き鳥
もいただきます
いただきます
食べてからのお酒がおいしいんですよね
ここで水神ソーダも行きます
[音楽]
やばい本当においしいから
余計
美味しく感じますね
夏最高ですねこれ
夏最高だねやっぱ閑散とゆずの香りと
甘すぎないからやっぱ食事に合う感じが
居酒屋メニューに合うのはちょっとこれ
本当ですね本当に身をもって体感するよ
満足しましたごちそうさまでしたちょっと
ごめんなさい一人だと絶対食べれないので
ちょっと畑メンバーとかスタッフの方とか
呼んでみんなで食べたいと思います皆さん
よく集まりましたたくさん食べていって
ください
乾杯
いただきますいただきます
[音楽]
最高です
焼き鳥を食べましょうかいただきます
いただきます
[音楽]
夏終わったもうやり切った
フィナーレだね
一人で家で一人で
だからちょっとこんな大人数は
緊張しちゃいますね一人で飲むのすごいな
買い物で見かける時は
酒しか入ってないです
結構好きです
[音楽]
よ
最後に一緒にお酒飲んだ人の性別は女の子
ですこの人数で食べるのも難しいかもしれ
ないのでちょっと裏にマネージャーさんと
かいるので渡していきたいと思いますさっ
さんどうぞいただきます
[音楽]
こんなスイスイだけにですけどこんな
スイスイ食べれるもんなんだなもうないよ
え余裕
余裕だった水曜日ですよ
[音楽]
こっちもなくなっちゃったよ
最後どうぞ
[音楽]
種付けちゃってるよ
ごちそうさまでした
美味しかった
はいというわけで今回4mの焼き鳥を作っ
て
焼き鳥と一緒に水神ソーダを飲んでみたん
ですけども両方
めっちゃ美味しかったですというわけで
今回飲んだ水神ソーラー缶リニューアルし
ましてゆず感がアップしてました
炭酸カも増しててもう
暑い日とかにグッと飲むととっても
美味しかったですもうね場所と
焼き鳥そして水神ソーダがもうぴったり
合ってたのでもうねこれはねみんなもやっ
てください水神相談居酒屋飯に
めちゃくちゃ合うので皆さんもぜひ飲んで
みてくださいもうね暑い夏にぴったりだと
思います僕も満足したので
明日は終わりですありがとうございました
[音楽]